ça a démarré à l'épisode 2 bat déjà dès
le début mon pris en grippe ne sais pas
pourquoi j'ai un fort caractère jeune
frère personnalité ça c'est pour ça
qu'on t'aime aussi je sais pas faire
semblant en fait moi je suis j'arrivais
pas à jouer la comédie moi je suis comme
ça c'est à dire que je dis ce que je
pense mais peut-être ma confiance en moi
mon ex sg pas un excès de confiance en
moi mais je suis quoi tu te dis donc ça
fait confiance en moi c'est normal sinon
pas son métier moi si vous êtes adepte
de vie que vous élevez par confiance en
vous est ce compliqué tu quittes qui
voit ici regardez voyez ils ont tous
c'est vrai et sinon il travaillera peu
plus
posé la question mais qu'est ce que j'ai
fait mais ils me disent mais t'as rien
fait de mal c'est juste en fait t'es
tellement consciente des tellement forte
notamment une forte personnalité tu
parles
peut-être que ça ça dérange les gens qui
ont moins confiance en eux je ne sais
pas j'en mets mais après il ya dix ans
moi je reviens de dix ans après mon
dernier koh lanta 7 en 2012 il ya dix
ans c'était pas comme ça ne rentrait de
colomb temps descendez de l'avion à
paris bien super aigles et c'était fini
mais maintenant avec les réseaux mais je
comprends mieux vraiment parce que moi
je répondais à tous les trucs qui était
vraiment nature et certains alors odenas
là-bas malheureusement il va y jouer de
leur image mais ça je me disais un
moment j'aurais dû faire comme ce qui
paraît qu'au départ vous répondiez sur
les réseaux ouais parce que je me dis à
partir du moment où tu écris faut
répondre et mais je répondais gentiment
mais gentiment voie au bout d'un moment
il ya tellement de flux qu'on peut pas
répondre ça vous verrez aujourd'hui je
serais pour régis vous avez reçu
également des menaces de mort c'est allé
tellement loin de votre employeur avait
même été contacté lui aussi menacé mais
en fait moi j'avais des it hurts comme
on dit ne pas d'accent qui avait
descendu en flèche la boutique que je
dirigeais à l'époque sur sur google donc
c'est un vrai effectivement ils ont dû
faire un démenti officiel si vous avez
reçu des menaces de mort aussi moi j'ai
reçu des menaces de mort éternelle 10
equal sur mes filles qui en repos
qu'avait quatre ans ici les
photomontages dégueulasse enfin j'ai eu
la totale mois il ya eu vraiment de
période koh lanta n'y première ou
j'existais pas ça me fait rigoler les
gens bien et à partir du moment où j'ai
fait sortir les premiers favoris on va
dire là j'ai pris cher j'ai vraiment
pris cher mais c'est à base de le
générique défile on vote on va le
générique des films et mon téléphone a
sonné dans tous les sens non je reçois g
mais linkedin pour ravir a poursuivi le
coach comme genre de message mais à la
base c'est us à rien un ca de mettons
c'est marrant mais après ça a été les
les fameux fdp qu'on reçoit en cascade
je vais pas vous faire simple ce que ça
signifie et puis après les menaces d'un
gars dégorgement
mois il ya eu il ya le lieu de travail
de ma femme qui a chuté aussi donc il y
avait des appels aller lui casser la
tronche c'est pareil sur le collège de
mon fils ça s'arrêtait plus en fait à un
point c'était même que mon téléphone en
fait c'est c'est la société c'est hype
et qui gérait en fait moi je gérais
savoir maintenant mais ça va ça devient
n'importe quoi mais on n'a même pas
envie de 2,6 en fait on se dit ça on
joue on va être mal vu et forcément
banahan koh lanta c'est notre aventure
faut que les gens comprennent que koh
lanta c'est notre aventure on le vit on
est on est soumis à la fin on est
fatigué on réagit pas comme dans la vie
de tous les jours moi là bas j'ai des
sauvages wager l'assument j'étais
sauvage et c'était mon dieu je les
aventures nos mais avec du sucre et avec
du repos je n'aurais je sais voix
l'agencé vivre en société je ne sais
plus je ne fais pas que de crier je ne
fais pas non plus en plus en vrai c'est
vrai qu'on est quand même un petit peu
sur les nerfs quand on est
énormément
justifier la wii en ce sens vous avez
vous dit à un moment donné on est un on
se sent obligé en métal c'est souvent ça
piège c'est ça ici on dit rien s'est il
dit rien parce qu'il sait qu'on a raison
mais si on commence à se défendre à il
se défend parce qu'il sait qu'il a
d'abord été un moment donné on sait même
plus sur quel pied danser en fait on
voit la balle est un moment tu as
d'abord sellal aventure ou pas du tout
pas du tout vous avez vous aviez une
protection policière ont pas du tout non
en fait réellement exe déposer plainte
quand ça commence et moi j'habite dans
un petit village c'est à dire que vous
allez dans mon village où dit il et où
régis tout le monde va vous le dira
d'accord donc un moment donné
la gendarmerie parce que chez moi c'est
la gendarmerie on dit ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va faire des rondes un peu
fréquentes mais plus dans l'idée qu'on
dégrade pas ma voix l'usure ou qu'il n'y
ait pas écrit tags et je sais pas quoi
sur les murs